Oh
[Music]
jean-paul Sartre says everything has
been figured out except how to live so
perhaps the better question is not what
are we to do with death but what are we
to do with life life exists in
individual moments and it is up to us to
make sure that those moments are vast
interconnected and grant to make a
masterpiece out of life one that we will
willingly live again and again for all
of eternity
this is what we could strive for and I
love this idea this idea of
aestheticizing our lives of italicizing
our experience of turning our story into
the story of seeing the universal in the
specific and sort of aligning ourselves
with the archetype of the hero's journey
of trying to see a departure from the
ordinary in every single instance a
chance to learn something new a chance
to leverage obstacles and learn from
them and meet people along the way they
can teach us something it's what the
movie Eat Pray Love talks about quest
physics the physics of the quest if you
believe and you're willing to step out
of your comfort zone life will begin at
the edge of your comfort zone if you're
able to treat what seems like despair
what seems like hardship as an
opportunity to reinvent yourself if you
transcend your own limitations as Steven
Johnson says the world is full of clues
and you can read your way through it if
you're able to turn your life into an
art piece if you're able to turn your
narrative into the UH narrative then you
become that hero you become the god of
your own life it's the archetype in
every film is the Joseph Campbell hero's
journey and that's just rad that's just
a cool idea
you
[Music]